foreign
Richardson you may vaguely remember the
name of someone who was complaining a
while ago about being persecuted for
some reason or another and supposedly
was all racist or somehow or something
all these controversies bleed together
in the mind and it's hard to keep them
straight so to clarify Richardson is the
female track star who was disqualified
from the Olympics a couple of years ago
because she tested positive for
marijuana and many people including
Richardson herself complained that the
rule against marijuana use is absurd and
pointless as marijuana is not likely to
give you an advantage in competitive
Sports this is probably true I guess but
me being the victim blamer that I am I I
always more so wondered why she would
use marijuana when she's in the middle
of qualifying for the Olympics given the
fact that it's a banned substance it may
not be necessary to ban it at the
Olympics but it's even less necessary
for Olympians to use it
and if I was hoping to compete in the
Olympics and the Olympics had a rule
outline the consumption of anything like
if they had a rule outlawing the
consumption of Cheez-Its before
competing and they had a test to
determine who had used Cheez-Its I'd be
severely disappointed I'd be confused I
wouldn't agree with the rule but I still
just wouldn't eat the Cheez-Its as
difficult as it would be to abstain
because it would be more important to me
that I get to follow my dream and
compete
but that's just me so she chose to
sacrifice the Olympics so that she could
smoke weed um that makes her the
and that's really the story there it
should have been but Richardson became
famous for not racing at the Olympics a
famous victim of Olympic rules that
apply to everyone but somehow were
personally oppressive to her
specifically and given that Richardson's
primary claim to fame is her victimhood
it perhaps is no surprise that she is or
at least became a totally insufferable
brat which leads us to the latest update
in the Richardson victimhood Saga where
now she finds herself kicked off of an
American Airlines flight after refusing
to stop using her phone before takeoff
she recorded two videos documenting this
confrontation with the flight attendants
and other people on her flight
apparently convinced that she comes off
as the good guy in The Exchange
but you can judge for yourself here's
the video
place it all the way under the seat in
front of you larger carry-on luggage why
are you not working today if you have
small vacation time such as cell phones
tablets and smart watches okay please
switch them recording me but you jumped
in my video so I called you because you
jumped in my videos you're harassing me
at this point so I think you should stop
I think you should stop I think you
should stop
y'all see him right y'all see him right
okay okay but I'm sorry it's not me okay
talk to him no no no don't talk to me
like that I'm gonna do not talk to me
like that do not talk to me like that
tell him to stop if you do not know
what's going on do not yell at me you
can stop recording no I'm not gonna stop
recording because I was making a video
to myself I'm going to not stop
recording
and this video will show what you're
doing so I appreciate it
are you talking to me thank you like to
know
again again with the taking the video in
public think why are you why are you
taking a video to begin with on your
flight no one cares that you're you're
on a flight you're taking a flight no
we've that's not interesting why do you
think that needs to be documented not
everything needs to be documented okay
we don't need we don't need
documentation especially not all the
documentation anyone does anymore is of
their face is a selfie or selfie video
here's my face on a plane here's my face
doing this here's my face walking down
the street nobody cares it's not
interesting
and I know that I sound like a hypocrite
because I'm in front of a camera every
single day but that's also my job and I
can tell you even in my job like it
trust me you see too much of me as it is
it could be a lot worse I mean all the
time I've got social media the social
social media team here telling me Oh you
should do this video doing this or that
we need a selfie video of you doing this
I'm not doing that no one needs to see
that it's it's not interesting like give
me a reason why I should be on camera
some reason and I'll do it but we don't
need you don't need to have your face on
camera every second of the day
okay
now in the second video which I won't
force you to watch she argues with
another passenger who rightly blames her
for holding up the plane and making him
miss his connection she chides him for
um not being chivalrous and and you know
not standing up to defend her against
the intimidating flight attendants and
he responds to her by saying and I quote
I don't give it which is both an
eloquent argument and the immorally
correct one in this situation eventually
Richardson has escorted off the plane
while the other passengers applaud but
the fact that nearly everyone on the
plane was against her and that she had
inconvenienced over 100 people for no
reason at all was not enough to convince
her that she was herself the villain of
this story instead she posted both
videos to Instagram while threatening
legal action against the airline for
committing the crime of I guess
expecting her to follow the rules that
everyone else has to follow
this is a theme for Richardson right she
really has trouble with requirements
that apply to everyone you don't have to
like the requirements okay but they
apply to everyone and no one else has a
problem everyone else manages to follow
them but you
why is it a problem for you everyone
else managed to not smoke weed before
they have to had to go race in the
Olympics you had an issue with it
everyone else manages to like not be
taking a selfie video right before
takeoff for some reason you can't handle
that
indeed she is personally injured by
these requirements the requirements are
an attack against her not against
everyone else who's just as subject to
them but against her because she is her
she is shikari Richardson and she is the
protagonist in the story of the human
species
now fortunately I don't have to go to
Great Lengths actually in this
cancellation to explain why Richardson
is in the wrong because it would seem
that most people are on the same page on
this one somewhat shockingly this is the
part that surprised me Richardson has
not garnered much public support even
after playing both the race and gender
card after the fact an Instagram post
that diligently avoids anything
resembling punctuation or proper
sentence structure Richardson wrote in
part
tell me if I'll be wrong to pursue legal
actions against the airline American
Airline not only did the man threaten me
but also an innocent bystander simply
just wanted a picture with me in the
beginning of the video you can hear a
Caucasian male state that he doesn't
give a f as a man that male flight
attendant is intimidating a woman also
the captain not doing anything to help
the situation and this flight attendant
has the Applause when I exited the plane
when I'm pretty serious the disrespect I
receive would not have happened if I was
a one if I was a one of them
I I
don't know
um one of them as in a white male I
guess is what she she meant to say
because of course
everyone on the plane would have been
perfectly happy to miss their connecting
flights if only the disturbance had been
caused by a white male I mean I'll never
forget the time it's actually happened a
couple times when I uh I threw a temper
a random temper tantrum in first class
delayed the plane by 45 minutes caused
32 passengers to miss their connections
and everyone in the plane
um they were so proud of me they shook
my hands one by one to thank me for it
while the flight attendant showered me
with free flight vouchers and extra bags
of complimentary peanuts that is a thing
that definitely happened in real life
and not just in the fevered marijuana
soaked mind of shikari Richardson
anyway in this case her victim routine
seems to not be resonating as much as
she had hoped with the public it could
be that the public
has become suddenly intelligent and
Discerning which seems to be frank
extremely unlikely or it could just be
that people are simply sick and tired of
loud-mouthed crybabies with main
character syndrome who always seem to
find problems and drama in the sorts of
situations where everyone else manages
to get along just fine fine
it's perhaps interesting to note that
even as the public becomes increasingly
and unreasonably tolerant of
self-victimizing drama queens who look
for every you know opportunity to be
oppressed
they still don't want to deal with it on
an airplane
people these days will put up with your
shenanigans
in almost any situation that is until
your shenanigans might cause them to
miss a connection in Chicago
that seems to be where the line is drawn
and it's good that the line is drawn
somewhere
and that is why I must say indeed I
think we all say that shikari Richardson
is today canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]